a week see I don't be curly plays New
York and he's on a road trip across the
country everybody makes his notice for a
hot skinny here guys my name is Hans Kim
I know what I look like but nothing into
anime which is unfortunate because the
only women who are sexually attracted to
me all some of that pretty into anime I
think the whole thing I forgot I have
resting anime face I'm constantly
consoling I want a day like Oh Santa
Anna Mae
I started date as an Asian man
everything's Asian women are beautiful
animal things Asian better beautiful
which doesn't make any sense because how
do you think Asian woman are created
maybe [ __ ] oh yeah I'm a crucial part
in such a process please stop trying to
scare me because thank me I'm sure it
will be very beautiful
how about whether half will be great
engineers intense important people make
fun of Asian people for eating dogs
which I understand is or a pic to you
guys because in America dogs are like
family peppers but in Asia we treat our
family members like family hunters
it's a cultural thing said of buying an
animal we love my grandma would have
better deja bless you happy we see 30 of
the river
my agent friends make fun of me because
I like to eat General Tso's chicken the
hunt isn't General Tso's chicken is a
shitty Americanized version of something
authentically Asian I was like yeah but
my favorite movies rush hour 3 I'm
excited for the new Black Panther movie
coming out I thought that was a very
important movie we gave black children a
hero they could look up to and after
someone like one of the King jr. or
Malcolm X or Harriet not gonna buy it
angelito Rosa Parks Kofi Anan Desmond
Tutu Nelson Mandela
- [ __ ] baby go now they have a fake
person that goes look at that
cat ears Oh easy an asian schoolgirl
what are they gonna call the yellow
panda huh I mean I'm not racist I hate
people - or just another first maybe or
whether to stand I capable for their
souls
it's my level you know I wasn't playing
and I suck dude reading a book in Arabic
which kind of freaked me out but then I
saw him pull the corner of the page put
the [ __ ] away and I was like oh that
guy's got future plans beginning middle
and end and finish the narrative
structure I am single I have yet to be
my soul mate I'm beginning to think
maybe it's her fault she needs to get
out more she seems like a loser I think
I used to date a woman who's got and
choke sex and that's right do you enjoy
breathing or not
I love the ladies I don't think I could
ever have sex with a dude yeah sorry
fellas
I've never looked at a beautiful woman
like is there a version of her that's
bigger and hairier that was kindness I
was like mad at my butthole believe me I
think women are very beautiful but I
creep them out a lot because I think
women are like a beautiful scenic sunset
that can yell at you yeah like a
waterfall they can call cops like a
beach with a boyfriend
so you can't take a picture I was time
this dude is like we're so lucky Rock
eight can you imagine if most of the
gender we were attracted to wasn't
attracted to us back I was like wow it
was swell the time those losers you know
I I think women are very hard to talk to
my friend Joe it's like you learn how to
talk to women maybe or maybe women
should learn how to listen to Hans what
join I hear about the Federal Reserve
i delegated is one way it was like did
you know that my vagina is a 3d printer
sounds like technically incorrect your
move is a 3d printer only one thing with
lots of errors design was to pray and
the whole time it's printing isn't
waiting a 3d printer this is that it not
to be trade is that nice I'm glad I feel
like magnet birth would be like bro I
believe you so much protein and creatine
there were pregnancy
he was like 27 pounds when you go six
second old you sounds in the jet stream
is that I'll be discussing you know I I
don't like how autism is only disease
you can diagnose at a bar like hey this
guy talks like it's not hot cheese
lymphoma they do an autism yeah you're
book smart but I'm street smart oh
you're smart the way that's not
measurable or comparable I could be in
for you yes alright your criminal
assault aggravated assault stop
mentioning it hurts I don't understand
how these people in gyms trying to get
the biggest limp
this is 2020 we don't even need legs
anymore what what are you gym working
out there's inert in the basement
clearing out the bank account what are
you gonna send some bad it's nothing a
[ __ ] up BOGO deals Aegean Sea
we're not happy design for service area
for cancer yeah I mean I'm pretty you
know woke I think trans people should be
able to use whatever bastard they want
to use thank you
I don't think suicidal people should
because we make a mess I'm pretty well I
love rednecks rednecks are awesome
because they could survive in any
wilderness situation you put them in
except except the situation where
everyone has equal rights it kind of
[ __ ] them up you can live in a swamp
with an alligator what am I going to
call this happen minority smiles do
something try to pick the things I don't
think everyone who's patriotic is stupid
but I do think everyone is stupid it's
gonna be a little patriotic you got
nothing good going on in your life
you're gonna be like well at least
something here
[Laughter]
yeah like taking politics I mean I think
capitalism is fine if you want to do it
just don't make everyone play your
stupid game okay for tonight I don't
make your grandma play big warehouse and
she loses I like how Americans will say
communism never works as if we didn't
spend billions of dollars and kill
billions of people to make sure it
wouldn't work remember the war in
Vietnam we're pretty anxious about it
not working the commies it never works
because whatever people control the
media production their democratically
elected leaders misuse the dying it's
not relevant voice like the automatic
weapons
I'm not a communist I do support
disappoint any policies are Republicans
considered communism which is whenever
two or more people gathered to do
something nice before any quit yeah I
guess we won't be able to live at a
gangster's paradise anymore no more gang
bang I think I've every one thousand
dollars every month do you guys would be
a lot more bearable to be around there's
some money some plane needs to go to
Subway I live in a band so that I could
pursue comedy full-time so they didn't
think I was funny I'm sorry I'm trying
I don't someone's in the back like yeah
that was funny but not look at your man
funny never is that jokah an apartment
buddy
it's not a date inside of my van because
way evil shelter like the whole thing
with that so even if the date goes well
what you saying that happening is we go
for a drive good courage is matter we
arrived 45 minutes ago
[Applause]